Patrick Mooney of Comcast SportsNet
Chicago Cubs reporter all right recap
this situation Patrick of exactly what
has transpired and what do you think the
end results going to be Miguel Montero
is gone he is someone who really what
did bring a lot of value to the
clubhouse is someone he the Cubs wanted
that kind of edge that's why they
brought him into a last-place team and
he did mentor some younger players like
Kyle schwarber and he was very generous
with his time with Wilson Contreras as
he was broken into as a catcher who
would handle a world series pitching
staff but Theo Epstein was watching the
Cubs affiliate in Myrtle Beach and was
alerted via text about Montero's
comments the other night and he said it
took him about ten seconds to realize
that he wanted to get rid of Montero and
Theo is away from the team and looking
at all this paper on talent you know all
this on paper talent and realizing there
aren't many ways for a front office out
of uniform people to try and spark a
flatlining team and Montero was kind of
sacrificed for that idea but he had
decent numbers there this is in his
first moment where he speaks up it feels
like there's more to it than just what
happened with Arrieta where he says I'm
a straight shooter and I can't throw
anybody out if he doesn't get the ball
over the plate
Arrieta signs off and says I'm fine with
it which I would expect he would do that
no matter how he felt that what else is
attached to this situation where this
guy in his last year 33 year old catcher
making what 14 million they're going to
let him long way I mean there's there's
no doubt that Arrieta was sincere and
saying I love McGee I mean this is a guy
who who caught his no-hitter at Dodger
Stadium the night the Cubs were there
onesies
you know another Joe Maddon
kind of gimmick and I think you know I
think the kind of bottom line is that
miguel monteiro is no longer performing
like an all-star and if the Cubs were 20
games over 500 the way they were around
this time last year I don't think it
happens I mean the Cubs have kind of
played all these different cards in
terms of bringing up Ian Happ who is one
of their top prospects demoting schwöre
burr to kind of send a message and I
think they're kind of running out of
shock value moves at this point and I
think Montero is that guy who is kind of
you know after throwing Arrieta under
the bus he's the one kind of thrown
under the bus at this point and really
you know he's he had all this stature in
Arizona he was a clubhouse spokesman and
you know he could kind of push the
envelope a little more and you know Theo
just got to a point where he felt that
Montero wasn't worth the trouble anymore
the Cubs feel like contenders well I
said the front office is certainly
wondering that themselves I mean they
look at there only a game out of first
place and a really bad division and I
think you're starting to see the
calculus changed a little bit I mean Joe
Maddon the other night laughs it off
saying you know the lineup they rolled
out there would be questionable in
spring training that they'd be getting a
call from MLB headquarters and I think
they're pretty close to that point of
understanding that a rental player
getting one of those guys at the
deadline doesn't really make sense and
that you know it's not that hard to
envision you know that kind of exit a
press conference in October at Wrigley
Field where CEO kind of frames us as a
bridge year or a building year and
points to all these different guys
who've got experience and it really is
crazy to think because when
they showed up in spring training and
you looked at the moves they made moves
that really turned out well I mean Wade
Davis has been great who we are has been
exactly what they needed
John Jay's been a solid bench guy I mean
there's really there's so many elements
from last year's team on paper that
should translate and it just hasn't it's
really been a system-wide breakdown when
you look at you know pitching defense
and the offense Patrick thanks for
joining us and enjoy the ride there
Thanks that night Patrick Mooney Comcast
SportsNet Chicago Cubs reporter the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience